what's up guys
helen here wondering how long it's been
since i partied shared a drink
or just hugged somebody i don't live
with of course if you're a resident of
the hype house
the answer is five seconds ago and also
you just stuck your tongue in a
stranger's mouth
indeed amidst the cultural backlash of
the pandemic a certain class of famous
people
online influencers have reached new
heights of media attention
simply by refusing to stay the hell home
but even before the
unplannedemic hit online influencers
have been steadily dabbing
lip syncing unboxing and pranking their
way into increasingly bigger spotlights
all while re-writing the rules of 21st
century celebrity
they're often dismissed as not deserving
fame or being grossly self-promoting or
for being very bad people who are
officially uninvited to my birthday
party
but as tech talk star charlie demilio's
recent ascendance to the big screen of
the dunkin donuts menu proves
that's not stopping them so how did we
end up here
what's the deal are influencers just a
slightly different form of celebrity
or is something more nefarious going on
let's find out in this wisecrack edition
on
influencers what went wrong but first
in true influence or fashion we wanted
to do a little self promo
right now you can grab the t-shirt i'm
wearing and a bunch of other cool
designs on the wisecrack store
we just did a big update so even if you
visited before
now's the time to check it out we have
dad hats long sleeves t-shirts and even
these funky mugs
rep your fey philosophy channel in style
by visiting wisecrack.store
or hitting the first link in the
description we appreciate your support
and hope you like the new merch
now back to the show this might not be a
shocker but fame is not new
there's something unique about how fame
became live streaming yourself
lighting your mattress on fire or
terrorizing the people of tokyo with an
octopus tentacle
and to figure out why we need to talk
about this guy
alexander iii of macedon or as you know
him
alexander the great this 4th century
king was great
not because he dropped 200 racks on this
car at the age of 9
but instead because he created the
world's largest empire
in just 13 years but as scholar leo
brodie writes in his book
the frenzy of renown fame and its
history that's
not why we still know his name it's
because he was the first famous person
how did this smelly warrior rise above
all the kings before and after him
while our boy alex had an almost
superhuman craving for more land
he also had the cunning to know that the
most valuable real estate was
in the minds of those he ruled he was
obsessed with
carefully cultivating his reputation
claiming to be descended from the gods
and modeling himself after the brave
warriors from homer's poetry
in athens he was officially named a god
and not just in a morgan freeman kind of
way
and in some ways alexander nailed the
basics of fame that persist
to this day like billy mcfarland
inviting hot people to fire fest island
alexander understood the importance of
visual representation
that's always been crucial to fame
because if people are going to worship
you
they generally have to know
approximately what you look like
if you're tracking the evolution of
celebrities it helps to look at the
visual mediums that defined them in the
public eye
alexander was super picky about how he
was portrayed visually
only allowing his three favorite artists
to depict him from life
they typically did so in a way that
evoked helios the sun god
because ancient greece wasn't the time
for modesty and whereas coins were once
the exclusive realm of gods and mythical
heroes
alexander was the first to stamp his own
pretty face on currency
so sure alexander was a legend but he
was also kind of a regular dude who ate
with his troops and fought alongside
them
this is another theme we'll see
throughout our history of fame famous
people are often larger than life
yet also relatable folks you can share a
beer or a
goblet with his legacy as a conqueror
was cemented
as he spawned the first ever wave of
biographic books
here was a guy whose story was truly
worth telling
but alexander wasn't alone in his early
fame ancient greek and roman culture was
full of fame hungry folks doing
impressive things to inspire poets to
write about
them but in rome in particular
everything was about performance and
leading a public life
in the name of personal glory and civic
duty
the writer cicero even tried to pen an
epic poem about
himself deeply charismatic roman leader
julius caesar
out did the rest with his obsession with
triumphant parades
and elaborate gladiator shows what's
more
caesar was the first soldier to write a
narrative war memoir
and apparently as he lay dying
rearranged his toga as one final act of
image control
now caesar was not an influencer selling
his bathwater
that we know of that's partly because
consumer society was still a millennia
or two away and at this time
celebrity was mostly about big men doing
big things
you know conquering and leading and so
forth but as cultures changed
so would fame and keep in mind fame
hasn't consistently been in vogue
that's thanks mostly to this guy who
switched things up in the 1st century
a.d
by living humbly avoiding publicity and
promising
mad glory in the afterlife naturally
celebrity culture took a bit of a dip
but certainly didn't disappear and fame
would eventually smash
through the confines set by christianity
and further expand beyond kings and
rulers with
the renaissance see the renaissance
brought the rise of portrait painting
and the printed page both of which began
circulating
images of people all over europe this
moment was
all about the individual and with that
his or her fame
as brody puts it everyone who made a
career in public
was being made to realize how both art
and printing could make him more
symbolic
more essential and more powerful what's
more
portraits seem to scratch that itch that
everyone has to be remembered and to
have their individual essence captured
as leon battista alberti wrote in the
15th century
the face of a man who is already dead
certainly lives a long life
through painting this frenzy meant the
rise of more and more people being
memorialized with a paintbrush
the best example though still comes from
a monarch
queen elizabeth the first of england who
was self-consciously curating her brand
more than 400 years before you
downloaded visco
in a turbulent time elizabeth fiercely
controlled her own image
sending out pre-approved portraits all
over the kingdom to be copied by
artisans
she even issued a proclamation to have
all unapproved paintings destroyed
though it apparently wasn't enforced
while monarchs weren't sponsored by red
bull
the uh bold fashion choices of royalty
certainly trickled down through the
aristocracy
if the renaissance expanded access to
fame beyond kings and queens
the 18th century absolutely exploded it
the combined french and american
revolutions trumpeted the democratic man
and a slew of such men like the founding
fathers were thoroughly obsessed with
their legacy
likewise post-revolutionary war
americans were eager to celebrate them
with dumb legends like that cherry tree
thing in america
celebrity has always been far more
democratic centering itself
around the individual who seems to
possess that special
spark a spark which simultaneously the
spectator could believe that they too
possess and so not unlike any given
selfie challenge
portraits depicted the so-called
democratic man
via images like this of the low-key
homely ben franklin
meanwhile books pamphlets portraits and
caricatures
circulated like mad bringing ever more
faces and writings to the masses
and providing ever more avenues for fame
concurrently
fandom as we know it really started to
begin as philosopher jean-jacques
rousseau grumpily recounted
people who had never read his books
would come from miles away to gab with
the man
famous for his intellect strangeness and
striking adoption of armenian fashion
needless to say rousseau never enjoyed
these conversations
still imitating the look of your
favorite french philosopher
wasn't possible for most people until
the 19th century
when the industrial revolution brought
the fast cheap mass production of
imagery and of ready-made clothes shoes
cigarettes etc
fashion suddenly took on a whole new
layer that
of personal identity and folks often
dress to
impress by copying images of famous
people they'd get their hair cut like
lord byron
or wear gloves like prime minister
benjamin disraeli
uncoincidentally this brought about
first the rise of the dandy
due to dressed like famous aristocrats
even though they often weren't
and second a huge number of people being
brought to insane asylums for claiming
to be napoleon
still when it came to fame the most
profound change of this century
was the arrival of photography which
democratized the right to see your own
sexy mug on paper
it's said that lincoln credits his
success as much to a widely circulated
photograph of him
as he did to any awesome speech he ever
gave the photograph made him both
accessible
and someone to emulate the simultaneous
rise of journalism provided a place to
celebrate the newly anointed masses of
the famous
and the arrival of gossip columns let
you find out what your favorite general
was eating
or what snarky things he was saying
about his enemies in this way
by the end of the 19th century celebrity
had basically stopped being primarily
about heroic achievements like in
alexander the greats case
and started to really be about identity
how that identity is expressed
and how it can be mimicked by adoring
fans like when queen victoria
popularized a poofy white wedding dress
that for some inexplicable reason is
still with us today
at this point there were more ways to
become famous than ever before
but one development would blow our
concepts of celebrity
out of the water the rise of the motion
picture
while early film actors weren't even
named in the credits
it only took 14 years for a bonafide
star
system to form whereas theater actors
had been achieving various amounts of
fame since the 16th century
the movie actor was something different
projected on a giant screen
their emotions and their individuality
were far more accessible
and people fell instantly in love much
the way they would with youtube star and
pathological tattoo collector justin
bieber for much of hollywood history
most famous stars were women and they
were mostly naturalistic performers
appearing to portray themselves on
screen and portraying sensationalized
versions of themselves in the gossip
columns
as a result the connection between an
early movie fan and their favorite star
was intimate almost possessive it's no
wonder that movie stars soon began to
have their clothes ripped by mobs of
rabid fans
what's more because anybody can
technically play themselves
movies made the most glamorous kind of
celebrity seem like it was just one
killer audition away
further democratizing our collective
concept of fame according to movie
critic and author ty burr
above all the movies propagated the idea
that you didn't really matter
unless you were seen and seen they were
charlie chaplin emerged as one of the
first worldwide recognizable faces
his transcontinental railway tour
attracting mobs of adoring fans
notably and uniquely charlie made eye
contact in his films
as if to emphasize his own accessibility
to the audience
still most movie stars were both
relatable and inaccessible in their
glamour
people you could go to the theater and
dream of emulating
and as they did consumer spending and
the leisure industry
exploded as more and more people used
commodities and personal style to
imitate the stars
this wasn't some random byproduct
consumption
is key to the idea of the modern
celebrity as p david marshall puts it
celebrity taught
generations how to engage and use
consumer culture
to make oneself this was literalized in
the form of celebrity endorsement
which began to really boom in the 1920s
subsequently every development that
affected the film industry
from the rise of the talking picture to
the rise of people magazine
to the rise of hell on earth has brought
stars closer to us
making them more accessible but perhaps
nothing changed the possibilities of
celebrity more than
this good thing it turned on that tv
lisa that's right
the television while the big screen bred
reliably glamorous stars
tv which rapidly took over america
provided the space for a different kind
of celebrity
the tv star was even more accessible and
democratized
the regularity of television programs
spread
familiarity intensifying the sense that
you really know the star as a person
most emblematic of early tv fame is
lucille ball
a then b-list movie actress who was a
non-hollywood approved 40 years old when
her show started
i love lucy was about a woman who wanted
to be a star
thus as burr explains it explored the
distance between the average person
and fame and the pain of that desire for
celebrity
coming up short such themes were
doubtless very relatable to an america
still absorbing the implications of
hollywood fame
but as tv contributed to the destruction
of the studio system
we also saw the parallel rise of new
hollywood
and with it the quote unquote common man
in film
exemplified by the likes of dustin
hoffman and gene hackman
we'd come a long way since the most
famous people were kings and queens
as fame became entirely about being
watchable celebrity became an accessible
dream for anyone with that
special something but the single biggest
step in this process
may have been the arrival of reality
television
developed in the late 1980s when tv
studios were slashing costs
reality tv emerged as a cheap production
model that banked on nameless talent
but by the early aughts it was
dominating the medium
beginning a cycle of everyday people
being made famous before being cast
aside for the next set of freshly tanned
faces
if a glamorous silent movie star
inspired the desire to imitate
and the more accessible lucy inspired
relatability
reality tv inspired a more total
identification with the stars in front
of us
they formerly nobodies were now some
buddies on our screens
they exemplified the paradox of
celebrity being extraordinary
while being totally ordinary and unlike
being born the son of philip of macedon
anyone could allegedly end up being
famous i made him through a good mutual
friend of mine
a grinder but most importantly reality
tv confirms the suspicions each of us
secretly harbors
that we deserve fame too and what's more
that we could achieve it
if only we could dance sing or sit in a
giant block of ice in a compelling way
scholar mark andreavic argues that
ironically
the increased democratization of fame
acted as a convenient collective fantasy
during a time of increasing economic
inequality
the idea that we could strike it rich on
the voice was a cheery antidote to the
fact that we can barely afford rent
but before fame could turn into watching
tana mojo self-immolate at her dumb
bootleg vidcon
there was still one step left we had to
not only aspire to celebrity
we had to become obsessed with the
process of celebrity making
you know like watching a viral star
shoot to fame before ruining his young
career by making fun of a dead guy in a
forest
whoa did we just find a dead person in
the suicide forest
and then watching the train wreck of
that person continually trying to revive
their career with pr stunts
this is what scholar tim mull calls a
hypertrophic celebrity culture
that is to say a culture in which we're
far more obsessed with
say the process of the pauls or the
kardashians becoming famous
and the mechanisms of how they achieve
that fame than we are with any one
particular celebrity
this process is literally baked into the
model of most popular reality shows
like american idol or the voice or
america's next top model
and so on in this era celebrities like
the kardashians become more admired for
their shrewd image control for how they
handle and enhance their celebrity
than for any other talents or abilities
i
still don't understand how paris hilton
got so famous but
by asking that very question i'm
probably contributing to this
hypertrophic celebrity culture
of course watching the process of a
normie or a hotel heiress become a
capital c celebrity
got a lot easier with the widespread use
of the internet and later
social media since then college student
jennifer ringley finagled a so-called
jenny cam that took pictures of her room
every three minutes
basically inventing vlogging the
internet has increasingly become a space
for staging our everyday lives
even more so than the idea that anyone
is one audition away from fame
the internet has brought us the idea
that anyone is one tick tock or vlog
away from the highest echelons of
internet stardom
the internet also offers the potential
for the micro celebrity
that is someone who is extremely famous
to a very specific group of people
like makeup or gaming enthusiasts
whereas we've always suspected that film
stars were playing
a perhaps heightened version of
themselves on screen internet stardom is
predicated on a strangely performative
sense of authenticity
fittingly some of the biggest stars of
the internet era
from the paul brothers to the mojo
sisters are ordinary
everyday people who happen to be good at
playing themselves
and happen to become famous for it
because of this supposed authenticity
more so than any celebrity before them
influencers cultivate an intense
parasocial relationship with fans that
is
a one-sided relationship in which the
fan gives love
likes and emotional investment while the
famous guy gives very little in return
other than an occasional thank you to my
fans
authenticity plus the strength of the
parasocial relationship
happens to make influencers perhaps more
so than glamorous movie stars
excellent salespeople particularly when
it comes to chicken nugget pillows it's
no wonder every corporation from adidas
to mcdonald's has taken note
fittingly influencers are also the
embodiment of this hypertrophic
celebrity culture
where your success at achieving fame in
the form of views or followers or a
movie deal
becomes far more impressive and
fascinating than any actual talents you
may possess
that's why every influencer seems to
inevitably celebrate earning 1 million
followers by doing something loony
as a culture we're fascinated by this
form of fame precisely because it seems
to be just
one successful instagram post away the
logical extension of the democratization
of fame that's been going on since the
renaissance
celebrity was once an aspiration to go
down in history for your deeds
or to improve your city's standing or to
secure your kingship
today fame and the spending habits it
can provoke amongst fans
is the point in and of itself this can
lead some click-hungry influencers to
make some very dumb choices
every evolution in media has made us
collectively more
visible being seen by millions has never
felt more accessible
more more important that's likely to
continue and just as the photograph
allowed more people than ever to become
more visible
and thus more famous than ever it's
never been easier to get eyeballs on
your face
however with each subsequent rise in the
number of celebrities
the entire concept of celebrity starts
to become devalued and eye-roll-inducing
basically more celebrities means fewer
have staying power
and nearly all are fated to quickly
become passe in a process that is either
sad or sadly funny depending on how much
of a jerk you are
now we're not saying to quit posting to
your dog's instagram
but do it for the joy of sharing
vandal's sexy mug
not with the hope of landing her a deal
with puppy chow but
what do you guys think is the
contemporary form of celebrity making us
all
fame crazed monsters or is the
democratization of fame
actually empowering even if your last
tick tock only got 540 views
let us know in the comments thanks to
our patrons for all your support
stamp that subscribe button like it's
your star on the walk of fame
and as always thanks for watching peace
[Music]
you